[موسيقى]
السعوديه مشاهدينا تعود الى الفضاء من
بوابه محطه الفضاء الدوليه يحمل رايتها
رائده الفضاء علي القرني وريان برناوي
برنامج تدخل التاريخ كاول امراه سعوديه
وعربيه تحلق الى الفضاء وتشارك زميلها
القرني في تطبيق اربع عشره تجربه علميه
وبحثيه طبعا من ضمن الابحاث
سي تجارب على الدماغ العصبي واربع تجارب
في الخلايا المناعيه ايضا الرحله تستمر
لعشره ايام تشمل ايضا تجربه استمرار واحده
وثلاثه تجارب تعليميه على بيئه الجاذبيه
الصغرى من فلوريدا الامريكيه تنطلق الرحله
بعد منتصف الليل بتوقيت الرياض وهي المره
الاولى التي يشارك فيها سعوديان في رحله
الى محطه الفضاء الدوليه دعونا الان
مشاهدينا نتعرف على بطلي هذه الرحله مع
زميلنا علاء تفضلي على اليك يا علاء شكرا
راويه وعادل اذا علي القرني وريان برناوي
رائده فضاء من السعوديه يحلقان خلال ساعات
ضمن المهام العلميه
الى وكاله الفضاء الدوليه من قاعده كبه
كنافيرال في فلوريدا وذلك بصحبه رائدى
فضاء امريكيين علي الجارني البالغ من
العمر 31 عاما هو طيار مقاتل برتبه نقيب
يقول
15 ويملك 12 عاما من الخبره في هذا المجال
اما ريان برناوي تعمل اختصاصيه ابحاث
ومختبرات هي حاصله على بكالوريوس علم
الانجاب والهندسه الوراثيه وتطوير الانسجه
من جامعه اوتاكو في نيوزيلندا برناوي تملك
تسعه سنوات خبره في الماء مجال الخلايا
الجذعيه السرطانيه كما حصلت على ماجستير
من جامعه الفيصل في مجال العلوم الطبيه
الحيويه من المقرر ان تدخل التاريخ كاول
امراه سعوديه وعربيه تنطلق في رحله الى
الفضاء اربعه عشره تجربه بحثيه وعلميه
يجريها رائد الفضاء السعوديان علي القرني
وريان برناوي ليسطرا للمملكه عصرا جديدا
في الفضاء ويلهما بلا شك ملايين الاطفال
في السعوديه والعالم العربي من اجل
استكشاف المزيد من اسراري الكون اعود الى
اعاده وراويه وتفاصيل اكثر عن هذه المهمه
شكرا جزيلا على
[موسيقى]
في لقاء خاص لقناه العربيه مع رائدى
الفضاء السعوديين على الجرني وريان برناوي
الزميل حسن الطالعي يتحدث معهم حول
التجارب والتدريبات المهمه وهذه المهمه
التاريخيه نتابع
ابرز الاشياء اللي خضعته لها حتى يتم
تاهيلكم بشكل كامل طبعا ولله الحمد اتمنى
مؤخرا الجمال التدريبات المتعلقه بالرحله
وكانت بشكل عام التدريب على المهام
اليوميه التشغيليه لمحطه الفضاء الدوليه
تدربنا على مركزين الابحاث الاوروبي
والياباني كذلك
التدريبات وجملتا على كيفيه التعايش داخل
المحطه الفضاء الدوليه وكذلك محاكاه
للانطلاق والعوده التدرب على الادوات اللي
بنستخدمها ان شاء الله في الابحاث العلميه
والابحاث
العمليه ان شاء الله على متن المحطه فهذه
التدريبات بشكل عام تثبت او او تمكننا من
القدره على النجاح في هذه المهمه وكذلك
بعد المهمه ان شاء الله نعود الى ارض
الوطن محققين جميع الاهداف المرجوه من هذه
الرحله
نتابع ايضا مشاهدينا مع رائده الفضاء ريان
برناوي التي تصف مشاعرها بعد اختيارها ضمن
المهمه العلميه الى الفضاء
احس كاني اتذكر موقف كانه صار امس يعني
كنت مستعده لابسه الباط الباط حق المختبر
حقي وخلاص طالعه من البيت رايحه على دوامي
اتصال يعني فرديت طلع الاتصال من الهيئه
السعوديه للفضاء
فاول ما كلموني قالوا لي ريانه انت الان
صرتي اقرب للحلم مبروك تم اختيارك كاول
رائده فضاء سعوديه تذهب لمحطه الفضاء
الدوليه يعني الجمله لحالها خلاص يعني صرت
ماني عارفه دحين اروح الدوام ولا اخذ
اجازه ولا انا الان رائده فضاء او باحثه
ما صرت عارفه يعني كيف اتصرف انا بحب عملي
في مستشفى الملك فيصل التخصصي انا اسكن في
الرياض واهلي في جده فاحد الاشخاص اللي
مهمين بالنسبه لي هي ستي ام الوالده كنت
حابه اني اقول لها الخبر وهي في جده
فطلعت على الغرفه جلست على السرير اتصلت
على العمل وطلبت يوم اجازه واخذت كذا من
الرياض لجده بس عشان ابلغها هذه الخبر
العظيم
سوف نقوم باجراء سته تجارب في الطب البشري
وهذه التجارب تعنى بدراسه التغيرات على
التي قد تصيب الدماغ الجهاز العصبي العظام
وكذلك النظر هذه الدراسات سبق وتم اجرائها
في بيئه الجاذبيه الصغرى ولكن الجديد انه
سوف يتم استخدام اجهزه جديده لاول مره في
الفضاء بشانها المساعده في تسريع النتائج
والتحاليل ان شاء الله وكذلك في الاستمطار
الصناعي وهذه التجربه فيزيائيه تعتبر كاول
مره تحدث كذلك في الفضاء وهي من شانها او
كفيله نتائج هذه التجربه بزياده ورفع
كفاءه الاستمطار الصناعي في الارض من 15%
الى اكثر من 50% ان شاء الله وسوف تساعدنا
باذن الله في الاسهام على مكافحه التصحر
ومشاريع السعوديه لرؤيه 2030 مثل الرياض
الخضراء والشرق الاوسط الاخضر باذن الله
طبعا ينضم الينا عبر الهاتف مستشار هيئه
الفضاء السعوديه الدكتور هيثم التويجري
الدكتور صبحك الله بالخير يعني اليوم هل
نستطيع ان نفرح الان بهذه التجربه ونقول
هي تتويج لعمل وطموح ام انه لا والله نحط
عيننا على القادم والقادم اكثر ربما
في البدايه وانا اخوك صباح الخير وصباح
صباح المشاهدين الكرام في البدايه يعني
الواحد لازم يعني يرفع خاصه الشكر والعظيم
العرسان لمقام خالد الشريفين الملك سلمان
صاحب السمو
الامير محمد
ال سعود ولي العهد رئيس مجلس الوزراء
لانهم الداعمين الكبراء اللي دعموا هيئه
السعوديه للفضاء والاطلاق هذا البرنامج
اجابه سؤالك يعني طبعا هذه
رحله تاريخيه
يعني زي ما تفضلتوا بوجود رائد الفضاء
منطلقين لكن
ان شاء الله ان شاء الله القادم اعظم
دكتور ماذا يعني بالنسبه للسعوديه
والسعوديين بانه اول عربيه ستطا يعني او
تذهب الى الفضاء هي سعوديه ماذا يعني هذا
الكلام للمراه السعوديه للسعوديه في هذه
المرحله من تاريخها وكل التغييرات اللي
حصلت مؤخرا
في الحقيقه يعني كان
ريانه راح تطلع وتكون ان شاء الله اول
رائده قضاء عربيه مسلمه يعني هذا طبعا
فخر كبير
المملكه بحيث انها
تظهر امام العالم
مدى اهتمامنا حنا بالمراه واهتمامنا في
دور المراه في المجتمع وكيف انه ممكن تكون
هي يعني رائده يعني زي ما يقولون
الجيل القادم هل هل نعتبر القرني وبرناوي
هم بدايه الغيث وانه القادم اكثر يتم
تجهيز رواد فضاء قادمين في المستقبل
ان شاء الله يعني القادم افضل
واعظم ان شاء الله ان شاء الله شكرا جزيلا
لمستشار هيئه السعوديه للفضاء الدكتور
هيثم تويجري يبدو ان السعوديه لن يكتفوا
بالاغنيه فوقها مسحب وربما
في الفضاء باذن الله
[موسيقى]
والله وبصراحه فخر مره كبير لنا
وشيء نعتز فيه كلنا يعني
الله يوفقها ان شاء الله وترجع للخير
البلد ولاهلها والناس كلهم ان شاء الله هو
حدث كبير تاريخي مهم يحسب لانجازات هذا
الوطن الكبير شعورنا عموما كشعب دائما
يملاه الافتخار احس بالفحر يعني هذا الشيء
اللي راح يصير صراحه اشعر بالفخر
والاعتزاز كوني سعوديه وان هذا الحدث
بيمثل الوطن شيء يعني مشرف للبلد يعني
الحمد لله ازدهار وكل يوم نشوف حاجه جديده
يعني للبلد نحمد الله على ذلك والى المزيد
باذن الله تعالى
[موسيقى]
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات